Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. At length the air began to grow grey with light, then swift golden arrows came flashing across the snow, and at last the glorious sun peeped up above the lava wall and looked in upon our half-frozen forms and upon Ventvergel, sitting there amongst us, stone dead. No wonder his back had
感谢您收听《历史其余部分》。想要获取每周的独家加更节目、无广告收听体验、系列节目的抢先收听资格，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。过了许久，空气中开始泛起微光，接着，金色的光箭迅速掠过积雪，最后，壮丽的太阳从熔岩墙上方探出头来，注视着我们半僵的身体，以及坐在我们中间、已经彻底死去的文特维格尔。难怪他的背部
felt cold, poor fellow. He had died when I heard him sigh, and was now almost frozen stiff. Shocked beyond measure, we dragged ourselves from the corpse, strange the horror we all have of the companionship of a dead body, and left it still sitting there, with its arms clasped round its knees. By this time the sunlight was pouring its cold rays, for here they were cold, straight in at the mouth of the cave. Suddenly I heard an exclamation of fear from someone, and turned my head down the cave. And this was what I saw. Sitting at the end of it, for it was not more than twenty feet long, was another form, of which the head rested on the chest and the long arms hung down. I stared at it, and saw that it too was a dead man, and what was more, a white man.
会感到冰凉，可怜的家伙。在我听到他叹气时他就已经去世了，现在几乎已经冻僵了。我们震惊得无以复加，把身体从尸体旁拖开——我们所有人对与尸体为伴都有一种奇怪的恐惧感——任由他继续坐在那里，双臂环抱着膝盖。此时，阳光正将它冰冷的射线——因为这里的阳光是冰冷的——径直射进洞口。突然，我听到有人发出惊恐的尖叫，便把头转向洞穴深处。这就是我所看到的景象。在洞穴的尽头坐着另一个身影，因为洞穴不过二十英尺长，它的头垂在胸前，长长的手臂垂在两边。我盯着它看，发现那也是一个死人，而且更重要的是，是个白人。
So that, Dominic, is a thrilling moment from King Solomon's Mines, which was published in 1885, written by Henry Ryder Haggard. And basically, even if you've never read it, you will be familiar with it, because it was one of the best-selling novels of the Victorian age, continues to sell in bucket loads, massively, massively influential on everything from Tolkien to computer games. And I'm very familiar with your methods. You are a firm believer, are you not, Dominic, that it's the mass market kind of middle-brow literature that is a much better guide to the spirit of an age than, say, the great literary classics? I think that's, yeah, absolutely, Tom.
所以，多米尼克，那是《所罗门王的宝藏》中一个扣人心弦的时刻。该书于1885年出版，作者是亨利·赖德·哈格德。基本上，即便你从未读过它，你也会对它感到熟悉，因为它是维多利亚时代最畅销的小说之一，至今仍在大量热销，而且对从托尔金到电子游戏的方方面面都产生了极其深远的影响。我对你的套路非常熟悉。多米尼克，你是一个坚定的信奉者，不是吗？你认为，相比于诸如伟大的文学经典之类的作品，大众市场的中庸文学才是更能反映一个时代精神的指南？我认为是的，绝对是，汤姆。
King Solomon's Mines is not just an enormously influential kind of text of empire, of the British empire and of Britain's involvement in Africa. But I would argue it's a foundational text of modern popular culture, actually. So, I mean, Indiana Jones films, countless video games. If you've ever played Tomb Raider or Uncharted, if your children have played those games, they are playing versions of King Solomon's Mines. It's enormously important. So can you just give a very quick outline of the plot? We'll kind of look at the details later, but just kind of, because it's basically, it's a quest plot, isn't it? Set in Africa. It is, exactly. So King Solomon's Mines is set in late 19th century Africa. Our hero is Alan
《所罗门王的宝藏》不仅仅是一部对帝国、对大英帝国以及英国对非洲的介入产生巨大影响的文本。但我要说，实际上它也是现代通俗文化的奠基之作。所以，我的意思是，印第安纳·琼斯电影，无数的电子游戏。如果你玩过《古墓丽影》或《神秘海域》，如果你的孩子们玩过这些游戏，他们就是在玩《所罗门王的宝藏》的各种版本。它极其重要。所以，你能否非常简要地概述一下情节？我们稍后会探讨细节，但由于它基本上是一个寻宝故事的情节，不是吗？故事背景设定在非洲。正是如此，完全正确。所以《所罗门王的宝藏》背景设定在19世纪末的非洲。我们的英雄是艾伦
Quatermain. We'll go on to talk about him. He's a hunter, he's an explorer, he's an adventurer. And he teams up with a sort of little fellowship, Tom, I think it's fair to say. And they set off over this extraordinary, fantastical landscape. So incredibly parched desert, isn't it? Exactly. And they arrive at this mountain, and that's where the scene of the cave with the frozen white man. Exactly so. Exactly.
·夸特曼。我们接下来会谈到他。他是一个猎人，一个探险家，一个冒险家。汤姆，他与一个小小的同伴群体联手了，我觉得这样说很公平。他们踏上了这片非凡、奇幻的土地。所以是非常干旱的沙漠，对吧？正是如此。他们来到了这座山，而那个有被冻住的白人的山洞的场景就发生在那里。完全正确。正是。
They are heading into the blank spaces of the map. Again, something we'll come back to a little bit later. And they're in search of King Solomon's treasure mines. They believe that there's treasure there. There are also two other quests that are kind of overlapping quests, as in other more familiar, more modern quest stories. One of them is looking for his brother who has gone missing and one of their party tom is in disguise isn't he he may or may not be the lost king of a lost kingdom yes so this is very exciting they they go on all
他们正朝着地图上的空白区域前进。这也是我们稍后会回过头来谈论的内容。他们在寻找所罗门王的宝藏矿藏。他们相信那里有宝藏。还有其他两个任务，它们是某种相互交叠的任务，就像其他更熟悉、更现代的寻宝故事一样。其中之一是寻找他失踪的兄弟，而且汤姆，我们队伍中的一个人在伪装，对吧？他可能是也可能不是那个失落王国的失踪国王。是的，所以这非常令人兴奋，他们踏上了所有
these adventures they they find this this lost kingdom terribly um wicked and formidable supervillain who is the king of it, who they fight. And an incredibly sinister witch, isn't that? Gagool, who I'm sure we'll be talking about. Yes, absolutely. They discover the mines, they discover the caves, but of course they go down into the caves and they're trapped. And there's all kinds of sort of terrors and threats down in the caves. And would you believe it? They emerged triumphant at the end of the story. I don't think I'm giving away the end by saying- Not too big a spoiler there.
这些冒险，他们找到了这个失落的王国，还有一个极其邪恶、强大的超级大反派——也就是那个王国的国王，他们与他战斗。还有一个极其阴险的女巫，对吧？加古尔，我相信我们一定会谈到她。是的，绝对的。他们发现了矿藏，发现了山洞，但当然，他们走进了山洞却被困在了里面。山洞里充满了各种恐怖和威胁。你敢相信吗？他们在故事的结尾凯旋而出。我想我说他们凯旋而出并不算剧透结局——结尾没有太大的剧透。
No, that the heroes live to fight another day. Dominic, just one thing. One thing that really struck me when I reread it, because I read it as a child, hadn't read it since. It has the primal scene of white explorers coming to a distant land and impressing the natives with their knowledge of eclipses. So that is such a familiar trope. It appears in so many kind of adventure stories. And I checked, and this is the first time it's used, apparently. So that kind of gives an indication of how many... It's a massive cliche breeder. Yes, it is. In fact, almost every chapter... When you read King Solomon's Minds Now,
没有，英雄们留得青山在，不愁没柴烧。多米尼克，有一件事。当我重读这本书时，有一件事真的深深触动了我——因为我是在童年时读过它，之后就再也没读过。它拥有白人探险家来到遥远土地并用他们的日食知识震撼当地人的原始场景。所以这是一个极其熟悉的桥段。它出现在如此之多的冒险故事中。我查证过，这显然是它第一次被使用。所以这在某种程度上表明了它是多少……它是一个巨大的老套制造机。是的，确实如此。事实上，几乎每一章……当你现在阅读《所罗门王的宝藏》时，
so I reread it, as you did for this this having originally read it as a child and thought well it was brilliant as a child and um when you read it now almost every chapter seems stocked full of stereotypes and cliches but often that's because it's the first time yeah they were so it's all the scenes of them going into the mines and the caves and they discover dead bodies which everybody has seen if they've ever seen a hollywood It's King Solomon's Mines that creates that. Although having said that, of course, there are a lot of cliches that are bred of the Imperial Age that are liable to seem offensive now. So we'll probably come to that as well. Anyway, so Ryder Haggard, who is he? Right. So we're a history podcast, not a lit crit podcast so let's root king
我重读了它，正如你为了这次节目而重读一样，你最初是在童年时读的，当时觉得童年时读它简直棒极了；嗯，当你现在读它时，几乎每一章似乎都充斥着刻板印象和陈词滥调。但通常这是因为它正是这一切的始祖。是的，所以他们进入矿井和山洞的所有场景，他们发现了尸体——任何看过好莱坞电影的人都见过这种情节。正是《所罗门王的宝藏》创造了这一切。话虽如此，当然，其中也孕育了许多帝国时代的陈词滥调，现在看来可能会显得冒犯。所以我们可能也会谈到这一点。无论如何，那么赖德·哈格德，他是谁？好吧。所以我们是一个历史播客，而不是一个文学评论播客，所以让我们把《所罗门王的宝藏》
solomon's minds in history so henry rider haggard is a classic kind of child of empire somebody who goes out to seek his fortune in empire so he's the eighth of 10 children born to what's his name william haggard who claimed descent from a danish nobleman i read that's right yeah squat they were they're a family of kind of squires in norfolk and what's quite interesting about haggard is haggard not unlike his greatest fan who's jrr tolkien so you probably spotted many of the listeners the similarities with the lord of the rings in the in the story so tolkien was a massive fan of haggard haggard like tolkien from the very beginning has a sense of kind of loss and nostalgia and he's backward looking because
根植于历史之中。亨利·赖德·哈格德是那种典型的帝国之子，为了在帝国中发财而外出闯荡。他是威廉·哈格德（名字记不清了）的10个孩子中的老八，威廉自称是丹麦贵族的后裔。我读到过，是的，没错。他们是诺福克郡的乡绅家族。关于哈格德，相当有趣的一点是，哈格德——这与他的超级粉丝J·R·R·托尔金不无相似之处，所以许多听众可能已经在故事中发现了与《魔戒》的相似之处——因此托尔金是哈格德的超级粉丝，哈格德和托尔金一样，从一开始就有一种失落感和怀旧情结，他是个怀旧的人，因为
his family are one of those families who owns a lot of land in kind of rural England and with thanks to free trade and the the import of kind of cheap foreign food and stuff they their world is embattled and their world is kind of in decline well so Dominic did you did you read the Brandon Hall which was the setting of the go-between Harley's, Hartley's great novel, that was based on Ryder Haggard's childhood home. Do you know, I didn't know that at all. What a brilliant, well, The Go-Between is one of my favourite books. Well, there you go. It all connects. Very good. So anyway, they're sort of being squeezed. Now, Ryder Haggard's older brothers have gone to public schools and to Oxford or Cambridge. He was sent to Ipswich Grammar School. He was seen as
他的家族是那种在英国乡村拥有大量土地的家族，由于自由贸易和廉价外国食品等的进口，他们的世界腹背受敌，他们的世界正在走下坡路。那么，多米尼克，你读过《布兰登庄园》吗？那是哈利·利（Hartley）伟大的小说《送信人》的背景地，它就是以赖德·哈格德的童年故居为原型的。你知道吗，我完全不知道这一点。多棒啊，好吧，《送信人》是我最喜欢的书之一。好吧，你看。这一切都联系起来了。非常好。所以无论如何，他们正在受到挤压。现在，赖德·哈格德的哥哥们都去了公学以及牛津或剑桥。他被送到了伊普斯维奇文法学校。他被视为
less bright than his brothers, but in fact, his father was extremely rude to him and said he was a complete failure and you're destined to be a greengrocer. Yes, harsh, harsh words. Like Margaret Thatcher's father, Tom, who was a greengrocer. Anyway, obviously, William Haggard, who was a barrister, was completely wrong about this. But his childhood, I mean, you can see is a breeding ground for a lot that's going to appear later in his novel so he's um as a child he was very kind of keen on hunting shooting fishing all that kind of stuff yes will reappear and he had um he had a very sinister rag doll didn't he he did called she who must be obeyed and his nurse used this this doll to kind of menace him into obedience. So that's all part of the mix.
不如他的哥哥们聪明，但事实上，他的父亲对他的态度极其粗鲁，说他是个彻头彻尾的失败者，你注定只能当个菜贩子。是的，严厉的话语，严厉的话语。就像玛格丽特·撒切尔的父亲一样，汤姆，他就是一个菜贩子。无论如何，显然，身为大律师的威廉·哈格德完全看走眼了。但他的童年，我的意思是，你可以看出这是他小说后来出现许多元素的温床。所以他……作为一个孩子，他非常热衷于打猎、射击、钓鱼以及所有这类事情。是的，这些都会再次出现。他有一个……他有一个非常阴险的布娃娃，对吧？是的，叫做“必须服从命令的她”，他的保姆用这个娃娃来恐吓他，让他听话。所以这些都是他背景的一部分。
It is very much part of the mix. She who must be obeyed will definitely reappear in this story. So anyway, in 1875, he's 19 years old, Ryder Haggard. And his father discovers that a family friend who lives nearby, who's called Sir Henry Bulwer, is going off to South Africa to become the lieutenant governor of Natal. And he writes to him and says, I've got this absolutely useless son. He's going off to South Africa to become the lieutenant governor of Natal. And he writes to him and says, I've got this absolutely useless son. Because he'd failed all his exams, hadn't he?
这很大程度上是他背景的一部分。那个“必须服从命令的她”绝对会在这部作品中再次出现。总之，在1875年，赖德·哈格德19岁。他的父亲发现附近住着一个名叫亨利·布尔沃爵士（Sir Henry Bulwer）的家族朋友，他即将前往南非担任纳塔尔的副总督。他写信给他，说我有这样一个完全废物的儿子。他即将前往南非担任纳塔尔的副总督。他写信给他，说我有这样一个完全废物的儿子。因为他所有的考试都挂科了，不是吗？
He'd kind of failed military exams. He'd failed his, he never took his foreign office exams. I mean, right. Yeah. I think people sort of now say his father was actually quite harsh. A bit like Churchill's father. Right. And he's not, I mean, clearly he's not that stupid because he writes two of the best selling books ever written but um anyway it's all arranged he will go out to south africa and he'll
他算是没通过军事考试。他没过，他从没参加过外交部的考试。我是说，对的。是的。我想现在人们有时会说他的父亲其实相当严厉。有点像丘吉尔的父亲。没错。而且他并不是……我的意思是，很明显他并不那么愚蠢，因为他写了两本史上最畅销的书，但是……不管怎样，一切都安排妥当了，他将前往南非，
basically be a dog's body for the lieutenant governor of natal he will do things like organize big banquets and talk to the servants and which is actually what he does so he goes out there and he does this he spends his spare time out there on the veldt hunting and you know riding around and whatever. And kind of basically falling in love with Africa and falling in love with the idea that here there is a sense of grandeur and adventure that you don't get in Norfolk. Yeah. Oh yeah, absolutely. And he particularly becomes an admirer of the Zulus, doesn't he?
基本上就是给纳塔尔副总督当牛做马。他会做诸如筹办盛大宴会、和仆人谈话之类的事，而这实际上也正是他所做的。所以他去了那里，做着这些事，他把闲暇时间都花在了那里的草原上打猎、骑马等等。基本上就是爱上了非洲，并爱上了那种你在诺福克郡体会不到的宏大感和冒险感。噢，是的，绝对的。而且他特别成为了祖鲁人的崇拜者，不是吗？
He does. He sees in the Zulus a kind of a warrior class reminiscent of the ancient Spartans. I think that's absolutely right, Tom. Yeah, it's a very Spartans. I think that's absolutely right, Tom. Yeah, it's a very good comparison. I think that's exactly how he sees the Zulus. So at this point, the British who are there in South Africa, they are pushing ever further into the sort of north towards the heart of the continent, taking more lands.
他是的。他在祖鲁人身上看到了一种让人联想到古代斯巴达人的武士阶层。我认为这绝对没错，汤姆。是的，这是一个非常斯巴达人的。我认为这绝对没错，汤姆。是的，这是一个非常好的比喻。我想这正是他看待祖鲁人的方式。所以在此时，身处南非的英国人，正进一步向北深入大陆腹地，夺取更多的土地。
They're drawn eventually by diamonds and by gold. But of course, they're in conflict with not merely the Africans who are there, so like the Zulus, but another group of settlers who are the Boers. And who were there first. Yeah, who were there first. So the tension between the British and the Boers we will come back to in a second. One of his first pieces, actually, Tom, is about going to Zululand. So the British are poised to basically annex Zululand. In 1876, he goes and he sees a war dance, and he writes about it, one of his first articles.
他们最终被钻石和黄金所吸引。但当然，他们不仅与那里的非洲人（比如祖鲁人）发生冲突，还与另一群定居者——布尔人发生冲突。而布尔人是最早到那里的。是的，是最早到那里的。所以英国人和布尔人之间的紧张关系我们稍后再谈。事实上，汤姆，他的第一篇作品之一就是关于前往祖鲁兰的。所以当时英国人正准备吞并祖鲁兰。1876年，他去了那里，看了一场战争舞蹈，并把它写了下来，这是他的第一批文章之一。
He says, it was like coming face to face with great primeval nature, not nature as we civilized people know her, smiling in cornfields, waving in well-ordered woods, but nature as she was on the morrow of the creation. That tells you something about the British attitude to Africa and Haggard's attitude to Africa. The idea that it's primeval, that it's unspoiled by modernity, that somehow it's truer, cleaner, more authentic, but also it's more, I hate to use the word, this is the word Haggard would have used, he would have said it was more savage. He would, he would, but equally this sense of a kind of pristine warrior potency that perhaps has been diminished in britain yes but among the
他说，这就像是与伟大的远古自然面对面，不是我们文明人所知道的那种在玉米地里微笑、在修剪整齐的树林里起伏的自然，而是创造日之初的那种自然。这说明了英国人对非洲的态度以及哈格德对非洲的态度。那种认为它是远古的、没有被现代性玷污的、某种程度上更真实、更纯净、更地道，但也更……我不喜欢用这个词，但这正是哈格德会用的词，他会说它更“野蛮”。他会，他会，但同样地，这种对原始武士力量的感觉——这种力量在英国可能已经减弱了，是的，但在祖鲁人当中，你知道的，它可以一直追溯到正如他所说的那样，时间的开端。而且……有这样一个惊人的细节，当他说英国和祖鲁开战时——英国军队在伊散德尔瓦纳全军覆没，然后英国士兵在罗克渡口进行了英勇的防御，这也是电影《祖鲁战争》的主题。而赖德·哈格德实际上在战后亲自去参观了伊散德尔瓦纳的战场。据他报道，在那里看到了……那种你在吉卜林身上感受到的情绪，吉卜林鄙视泥泞的鸽子和身穿法兰绒的傻瓜，与祖鲁人相比，英国人作为战士在某种程度上是不严肃的。英国人获胜是因为他们拥有加特林机枪……喜欢非洲的浪漫主义、探索和冒险。但我认为他总是将正式的帝国视为一种失望，觉得它过于官僚、怯懦。有一个绝佳的例子。所以正如我们所说，在19世纪70年代末的这个时期，英国人正在向北推进并吞并领土。他们吞并的地方之一，在祖鲁战争后他们最终不仅吞并了祖鲁兰，还吞并了一个布尔人共和国——德兰士瓦。1877年，哈格德实际上作为一名打杂人员，是前往德兰士瓦首府比勒陀利亚的一员，由于原本要宣读公告的官员失声了，这份公告便由他来宣读。于是，资历尚浅的哈格德被委任在比勒陀利亚宣读吞并公告，并升起了英国国旗。这对他是非常骄傲的时刻。他认为我们的帝国是一项文明使命，诸如此类。这太棒了。但三年后，布尔人叛乱了。德兰士瓦爆发了起义。英国的政权发生了更迭。因此，热衷于帝国主义的迪斯雷利下台了，取而代之的是对帝国主义态度更为矛盾的格莱斯顿。英国人在马朱巴山遭遇了失败。我的意思是，这些都是相当规模较小的部队，但他们确实遭遇了失败。与此同时，哈格德已经成为了一名鸵鸟养殖户，不是吗？一名鸵鸟养殖户，是的，没错。他从自己的农场里听到了战斗的声音。他的确听到了。千真万确。所以他已经安顿下来了。此时他已经结婚了。他有了这个鸵鸟农场，位于德兰士瓦和纳塔尔的边界附近。英国人战败了。格莱斯顿不想投入大量的资金和人力以及所有这些东西。他只是说，好吧，让布尔人独立吧，管他呢。就在那时，哈格德说——这表明了这件事对他是多么私人的经历。
zulus is is you know it can stretch right the way back to as he says there the beginning of time and um there's this kind of amazing detail when he said britain and zulu go to war um british army gets wiped out at isambuana then there's a heroic a heroic defence by British soldiers at Rourke's Drift, which is the subject of the film Zulu. And Ryder Haggard actually goes and he visits the battlefield of Isandwana after the battle. And he reported seeing crushed there of that sense that you get with Kipling, who kind of despised muddy doves and flannel fools, that the British are in some way unserious as warriors compared to the Zulus. That the British win because they've got the Gatling loves the kind of romance of Africa, of exploration, adventure. But the formal empire, I think he always views as a bit of a disappointment, as kind of too bureaucratic, pusillanimous. There's a brilliant example of this. So as we said, at this point in the late 1870s, the British are pushing sort of north and absorbing territory. One of the places they absorb, they eventually end up annexing not just Zululand after the Zulu War, but one of the Boer
祖鲁人，你知道的，这可以一直追溯到他所说的世界之初，嗯，这里有一个非常惊人的细节，当他说英国和祖鲁开战时，英国军队在伊桑德尔瓦纳全军覆没，接着英国士兵在罗克渡口进行了英勇的防御，这也是电影《祖鲁》的主题。莱德·哈格德实际上在战后参观了伊桑德尔瓦纳的战场。他报告说在那里看到了破碎的景象，那种你在吉卜林身上也能感受到的感觉——吉卜林有点鄙视那些满身泥泞的鸽子和身穿法兰绒的傻瓜——与祖鲁人相比，英国人在某种程度上并不是严肃的战士。英国人取胜是因为他们拥有加特林机枪。他热爱非洲的浪漫主义、探索和冒险。但我认为，他总是将正式的帝国视为一种令人失望的存在，觉得它过于官僚主义、懦弱。这里有一个极好的例子。正如我们所说，在19世纪70年代末的这个时候，英国人正在向北推进并吞并领土。他们吞并的地方之一，最终在祖鲁战争后不仅吞并了祖鲁兰，还吞并了一个布尔
Republics, the Transvaal. And in 1877, Haggard is actually, as a sort of dog's body, he is part of the party that go from the Taal to north to the Transvaal to Pretoria, that he reads out because the official who's going to do it loses his voice. So Haggard, the junior person, is given the proclamation of annexation to read out in Pretoria, and he hoists the Union flag. And this is a very proud moment for him. He thinks our empire is a civilizing mission, all of this stuff. This is great. But three years later, the Boers rebel. There's a revolt in the Transvaal. There's been a change of government in Britain. So Disraeli, who was all for imperialism, has given way to
共和国——德兰士瓦。1877年，哈格德实际上作为一个跑腿的小喽啰，加入了从纳塔尔向北前往德兰士瓦比勒陀利亚的队伍，他宣读了公告，因为原本负责宣读的官员失声了。于是，身为资历最浅的人的哈格德，被指派在比勒陀利亚宣读吞并公告，并升起了英国国旗。这对他是非常骄傲的时刻。他认为我们的帝国是一项文明使命，诸如此类。这太棒了。但三年后，布尔人起诉了。德兰士瓦爆发了起义。英国的政府发生了更迭。因此，热衷于帝国主义的迪斯雷利，将权力交给了
Gladstone, who's much more ambivalent about it. The British suffer a defeat at Majuba Hill. I mean, these are quite small forces, but they suffer a defeat. And meanwhile, Haggard has become an ostrich farmer, hasn't he? An ostrich farmer, yes, exactly. And he hears the sound of the fighting from his farm. He does. He does indeed. Exactly right. So he's settled down. He's married by this point. He's got this ostrich farm, which is near the border between the Transvaal and the Tull. The British are defeated. Gladstone doesn't want to pour in a load of money and men and all that stuff. He just says, fine, let the Boers have their independence, you know, Sodom. At that point, Haggard said, show how personal this is for him.
对帝国主义态度更加矛盾的格莱斯顿。英国人在马朱巴山遭遇了失败。我的意思是，这些都是相当小的部队，但他们确实战败了。与此同时，哈格德已经成了一个鸵鸟养殖户，不是吗？一个鸵鸟养殖户，是的，完全正确。他从自己的农场里听到了战斗的声音。他确实听到了。他的确听到了。完全正确。所以他已经安定下来了。那时候他已经结婚了。他拥有这个鸵鸟农场，位于德兰士瓦和纳塔尔的边界附近。英国人战败了。格莱斯顿不想投入大量资金和人力之类的事。他只是说，好吧，让布尔人独立吧，管他呢。就在那时，哈格德说，这对他来说是多么的个人化。
The peace terms are actually negotiated at his farmhouse, which is called Hill Drop. And Haggard writes himself later, it was a strange fate which decreed that the retrocession of the Transvaal, over which I had myself hoisted the British flag, should be practically accomplished beneath my roof. Dominic, do you think that writer Haggard is the only famous British novelist to have kept an ostrich farm? I guess he must be. I can't imagine Jane Austen keeping ostriches. I thought you were asking me that because you knew that Henry James or Graham Greene. No, I don't. It's a genuine question. I simply cannot imagine. Iris Murdoch had once. Yeah, no, I can't imagine anyone else keeping ostriches anyway. But he comes back then, doesn't he, to Britain? This is the funny thing. This is the end of Ryder Haggard and Africa. It's on pretty much. He's been there for five years.
和平条款实际上是在他的农场里谈判达成的，该农场名为“山顶”（Hill Drop）。哈格德后来自己写道：“一种奇怪的命运注定，我亲手为其升起英国国旗的德兰士瓦的归还，竟然实际上是在我的屋檐下完成的。”多米尼克，你认为赖德·哈格德是唯一一个养过鸵鸟的著名英国小说家吗？我想他一定是。我无法想象简·奥斯汀养鸵鸟。我以为你问我这个是因为你知道亨利·詹姆斯或格雷厄姆·格林……不，我不知道。这是一个真正的问题。我简直无法想象。爱丽丝·默多克曾经养过。是的，不，无论如何我无法想象其他人养鸵鸟。但他随后回到了英国，不是吗？这就是有趣的地方。这是赖德·哈格德与非洲缘分的终结。差不多就是这样。他在那里待了五年。
He comes back and he says, this is a great betrayal by Gladstone and the liberals. He's like these people who are slagging off Gladstone because they see him as abandoning General Gordon. Anyway, this is the end of Ryder Haggard and Africa. He now comes back and he decides he's going to be a lawyer. So he's called to the bar. He's a barrister. He tries his hand at writing novels and he writes two that are pretty useless.
他回来了，并表示这是格莱斯顿和自由党人的极大背叛。他就像那些抨击格莱斯顿的人一样，因为他们认为格莱斯顿抛弃了戈登将军。无论如何，这是赖德·哈格德与非洲缘分的终结。他现在回来了，并决定成为一名律师。于是他通过了呼唤出庭律师的仪式，成为了一名大律师。他尝试写小说，写了两部，但基本没什么用。
Yeah, not successful. Don't trouble the scorer. And then an amazing story. He is on the train one day going to London with his brother, one of his multiple, much more successful and impressive siblings. And they're talking about a new book, which has been a tremendous hit and the first of a genre, first of a new genre. That book is Robert Louis Stevenson's Treasure Island, which was published in 1883. Treasure Island was an enormous hit, and it appealed to an entirely new readership. So these are people who are newly literate because of the Education Act of 1870, which has expanded schooling in Britain. These are people who probably a generation
是的，不太成功。根本不值得记上一笔。然后是一个惊人的故事。一天，他和他的兄弟——他众多兄弟中更成功、更令人印象深刻的一个——坐火车去伦敦。他们在谈论一本新书，这本书大获成功，并且开创了一种新的流派，是新流派的第一部作品。那本书就是罗伯特·路易斯·史蒂文森的《金银岛》，出版于1883年。《金银岛》获得了巨大的成功，并吸引了全新的一批读者。这些人由于1870年的《教育法》（该法扩大了英国的学校教育）而成为新识字的人口。这些人如果在一代
or two earlier would never have been able to read and write. But they are, you know, books are cheaper. There are new newspapers. They love Treasure Island. They can't get enough of this derring-do and blood and thunder and all this stuff. And the whole thing about Treasure Island is that, again, that it's about pirates, Spanish Maine. It's a world that is somehow more glamorous and more dangerous than England. England. It's pure escapism rooted in a sort of kind of fantastical version of history, I suppose. And opens with a map. And opens with a map. There's a degree of a quest about it. You know, people in the 1880s love this kind of stuff. Anyway, Ryder Haggard says to his brother, well, I think I could, I don't think it's that great. I think I could do better than that. And his brother said to him,
或两代人之前，可能根本没有机会识字。但他们识字了，而且书变得更便宜了。有了新的报纸。他们喜欢《金银岛》。他们对这种惊险刺激、打打杀杀的故事百看不厌。关于《金银岛》的奇妙之处在于，它讲的是海盗、西班牙地盘的故事。那是一个比英格兰更迷人、更危险的世界。英格兰。这是一种植根于某种奇幻历史版本的纯粹逃避现实主义，我想是的。而且以一张地图开篇。以一张地图开篇。它带有一定程度的寻宝性质。你知道的，1880年代的人们非常喜欢这种东西。无论如何，赖德·哈格德对他的兄弟说，嗯，我想我可以……我觉得它没那么厉害。我觉得我能比那写得更好。他的兄弟对他说：
supposedly, there are two different stories. One, his brother says, I'll bet you, I think, a bob or something. And another is, he says, I'll bet you five shillings, whatever. He says, I bet you can't do it as well as Robert Louis Stevenson. Haggard says, fine, I'll do it. It takes him extraordinarily six weeks. I think you can sometimes detect traces of that in the writing, Tom, do you think? But authors are always saying that. Well, six weeks. I think you can sometimes detect traces of that in the writing, Tom, do you think?
据说，有两种不同的说法。一种是他的兄弟说，我跟你打赌，我想，赌一个先令或者别的什么。另一种说法是，他说，我跟你打赌五个先令，随便多少。他说，我打赌你写得不如罗伯特·路易斯·史蒂文森好。哈格德说，好吧，我来写。他花了惊人的六周时间。汤姆，你觉得有时能在字里行间察觉到这一点吗？但作家总是这么说。好吧，六周。汤姆，你觉得有时能在字里行间察觉到这一点吗？
But authors are always saying that. Well, I know. I say that about writing my vampire book. Did it take you six weeks? I always say it took me six weeks. Six years. And I realise it actually didn't. It took me slightly longer than that.
但作家总是这么说。好吧，我知道。我写我的吸血鬼书时也这么说。你花了六周吗？我总是说我花了六周。六年。然后我意识到其实并没有。我花的时间比那稍微长一点。
I think it's kind of shorthand for he wrote it very fast. He wrote it very fast. So he writes King Solomon's Mines, his own quest story set in a version of the Africa in which he had spent five years. Right. Because that's the key thing, isn't it? That actually, I mean, he's saying that, you know, there are unknown reaches, but that's not true. I mean, there aren't, he knows full well that there aren't these huge deserts and these mysterious mountains. And any possibility of a kind of lost paradisal kingdom um which kokoana land isn't it that when they arrive there it's kind of it's more beautiful
我想这是一种简化的说法，意思是写得非常快。他写得非常快。于是他写了《所罗门王的宝藏》，这是一个以他生活过五年的非洲为背景的寻宝故事。没错。因为这才是关键所在，对吧？事实上，我的意思是，他在说，你知道的，那里有未知的领域，但这不是真的。我的意思是，并没有，他心里很清楚根本没有那些巨大的沙漠和神秘的山脉。而且存在着某种失落的世外桃源般的王国的可能性——也就是库库纳兰（Kukuanaland），不是吗？当他们到达那里时，那里更加美丽，
it's more intense everything is is kind of more glamorous and exciting the warriors are braver the women are more beautiful yeah um and it's a fantastical land but he knows full well that that doesn't exist uh he does tom but there are still blank spaces on the map kind of at the time that he's well we should come back to explorers we'll come back to explorers the thing that really puts publishers off actually is not the fantasy it's the violence so there's a lot of violence um there's a particular a scene which said that there's a brilliant um writer called katherine rundell yes uh the bug for of dunn Dunn, and also a prize-winning children's author. She wrote a wonderful essay about Ryder Haggard
更加浓烈，一切都显得更加迷人、刺激，战士更加勇敢，女性更加美丽，是的，这是一个奇幻的国度，但他心里很清楚那并不存在。他确实知道，汤姆，但当时地图上仍然有空白区域——我们稍后应该会谈到探险家，我们会谈到探险家的。实际上真正让出版商退缩的不是奇幻元素，而是暴力元素。这里面有大量的暴力，有一个特别的场景，据一位才华横溢的作家凯瑟琳·朗德尔（Katherine Rundell）所说——是的，邓恩的臭虫，也是一位屡获殊荣的儿童文学作家。她在几年前的《伦敦书评》上发表了一篇关于赖德·哈格德的精彩文章。她指出，
in the London Review of Books a couple of years ago. She points out that, she says, the highlight for most children when they read it is a bit when a young boy, a Zulu boy, is literally torn apart by an elephant. She points out that most children love this, which anyone who's written for children knows that this is almost certainly true. But the publishers were appalled by this.
她说，对大多数儿童来说，在阅读时高潮迭起的部分是一个小男孩——一个祖鲁男孩——字面意义上被一头大象撕成碎片的场景。她指出，大多数孩子都喜欢这个，任何为儿童写作的人都知道这几乎肯定是千真万确的。但出版商对此感到震惊。
So one publisher said, never has it been our fate to wade through such a farrago of obscene witlessness. Nothing is more likely in the hands of the young to do so much injury as this recklessly immoral book. So lots of them turn it down, but Castle agreed to publish it. They bring it out in autumn of 1885. They have billboards around London that describe it as the most amazing book ever written. I mean, you'd love that, wouldn't you? I would, of course, as an author.
因此，一位出版商说：“我们从未有过这样的命运，去在一堆淫秽、愚蠢的废话中艰难跋涉。没有什么比这本鲁莽而不道德的书更有可能在年轻人手中造成如此大的伤害了。”因此，许多出版商拒绝了它，但卡塞尔（Cassell）同意出版。他们在1885年秋天将其推出。他们在伦敦各地张贴广告牌，将其描述为“有史以来最惊人的书”。汤姆，你一定会喜欢这个，对吧？当然，作为一个作家，我会的。
And it's a massive, massive hit. And it's a hit, not least because this is the year of the Berlin Conference, when all the European colonial powers are meeting to divide Africa between themselves. The onset of the scramble for Africa. Exactly. It gets brilliant reviews, by and large.
而且它取得了巨大的、巨大的成功。它大获成功，不仅因为这是柏林会议召开的那一年，所有欧洲殖民国家都在开会瓜分非洲。非洲大瓜分的开始。正是如此。总的来说，它获得了极好的评价。
I mean, some people don't like it, but the Athenaeum, a journal, said the fighting scenes were hardly to be beaten outside Homer and the great Juma. Right. But the echoes of Homer again, the sense of primal warrior virtue and prowess at the beginning of time. Exactly. Still to be found in the heart of Africa. Now, funnily enough, Robert Louis Stevenson, who Haggard had set out to beat, he actually writes to Haggard and he says, you know, well done, tremendous book, you're fine, weird imagination. But he also says to Haggard, just be careful with your prose, you should slow down a bit.
我的意思是，有些人不喜欢它，但《雅典娜神庙》（The Athenaeum）杂志称，其中的战斗场面“除了荷马史诗和伟大的……之外，几乎无可匹敌”。没错。荷马的回忆再次涌现，那种在时间之初的原始武士美德和英勇无畏的感觉。正是如此。依然可以在非洲腹地找到。说来也巧，被哈格德视作超越目标的罗伯特·路易斯·史蒂文森，实际上给哈格德写信说，你知道的，干得好，这是一本极棒的书，你很不错，有着奇怪的想象力。但他也对哈格德说，写散文时要小心点，应该放慢一点节奏。
Which Haggard presumably found very condescending. And Haggard completely ignored because in the next few months, he pours out more books. So he writes a sequel called Alan Quatermain and another book, which you'll come to a little bit later, called She, which is another absolutely foundational text in our kind of popular imagination. And that sets him off. Just to finish with Haggard, he becomes a full-time writer. He makes lots of money. He becomes a country landowner. He tries to become a Tory politician. So he stands in Norfolk in 1895, but he loses.
哈格德大概觉得这非常居高临下。而哈格德完全无视了这一点，因为在接下来的几个月里，他接连创作了更多书籍。所以他写了一部续集叫《艾伦·夸特曼》，还有另一本书——你稍后会讲到——叫《她》，这也是我们大众想象中的另一部绝对奠基之作。这让他一炮走红。最后以哈格德作结，他成为了一名全职作家。他赚了很多钱。他成了一名乡村地主。他试图成为一名保守党政客。因此他在1895年在诺福克郡参选，但失败了。
That's quite a feat, isn't it? To lose as a would-be Tory MP in Norfolk. Well, I think in those days, Haggard claimed that he said the area could not have been more unfriendly to the unionist cause. I think possibly because of food. Cheap food prices meant that for agricultural labourers in East Anglia, these were tough times in the 1890s. Well, let's not get into free trade or anything like that. Let's stick to… But he becomes a famous kind of Africanist. So he's the head of all kinds of commissions and panels even though as we said he's actually only spent five years he writes um he writes a whole the zulu trilogy as well doesn't towards the end of his life featuring um and this is alan quatermain again featuring
这真是个壮举，不是吗？作为保守党议员候选人在诺福克郡落败。嗯，我想在那个时代，哈格德声称该地区对统一派事业的支持度可以说是冷淡至极。我想可能是因为食品价格。廉价食品意味着对于东盎格利亚的农业工人来说，1890年代是艰难的岁月。好吧，我们不要陷入自由贸易之类的讨论。让我们专注于……但他成为了一个著名的非洲研究专家。所以他担任了各种委员会和评审团的负责人，尽管正如我们所说，他实际上只在那里待了五年。他还写了一整套祖鲁三部曲，不是吗？在他晚年的时候，以……再次出现了艾伦·夸特曼，
zikali the dwarf wizard known as the thing that should never have been born which is i haven't read that tremendous a tremendous name that's a great if you were called that that is a truly great name and then his trajectory is almost slightly predictable so by the 1910s and 1920s he spends all his time going on about radicals and bolsheviks and and sort of international socialism and stuff you can imagine the kind of stuff he would have been putting had he had the internet oh yeah absolutely um yes he would have been putting had he had the internet. Oh yeah, absolutely. Yes, he would have been cancelled, I think it's fair to say, Tom. Although not everybody had read King Solomon's Minds or She, it's a bit like Star Wars or James Bond today, or Spider-Man, dare I say, Tom. Never heard of it.
其中出现了齐卡利（Zikali）——那个被称为“本不该出生之物”的侏儒巫师。我没看过那部作品，这是一个极棒的名字，如果你叫这个名字，那真是一个伟大的名字。然后他的轨迹几乎是可以预测的。到了1910年代和1920年代，他把所有的时间都花在抨击激进分子、布尔什维克以及国际社会主义之类的事情上。你可以想象如果他有互联网，他会发些什么样的内容。噢，是的，绝对会。如果他有互联网，他会发那些东西。噢，是的，绝对的。是的，我想他会被“取消”的，汤姆，这样说很公道。尽管并非每个人都读过《所罗门王的宝藏》或《她》，这有点像今天的《星球大战》或《詹姆士·邦德》，或者我敢说，汤姆，还有《蜘蛛侠》。从未听说过。
Almost every sort of thinking, reading person in the English-speaking world would have been aware of those books, of the Alan Quatermain character, and of the cliches and the kind of the tropes that- Yeah. Conan Doyle's Lost World, the idea of Tarzan, all that kind of stuff. The people going from the Imperial Metropole to distant reaches and discovering extraordinary treasures. And Dominic, I mean, going back to the book, one thing that we haven't explained is the title. What are King Solomon's mines doing in South Africa? It's quite a long way from Jerusalem. That is also a kind of enduring part. You mentioned Indiana Jones,
英语世界中几乎每一个有思考能力、有阅读习惯的人，都会知道这些书、艾伦·夸特曼这个角色，以及那些……——是的，柯南·道尔的《失落的世界》，泰山的理念，所有这些东西。人们从帝国都会前往遥远的地区并发现非凡的宝藏。多米尼克，我的意思是，回到这本书本身，有一件事我们还没有解释，那就是书名。所罗门王的宝藏在南非干什么？这离耶路撒冷可够远的。这也是一个持久的主题。你提到了印第安纳·琼斯，
the idea that there are lost civilizations uh waiting to be discovered and that um and this is quite kind of atlantis we talked about this in the the atlantis thing the idea that if there are ruins and ancient civilizations to be found in africa the assumption is that they are not actually african in origin yeah that it is outsiders who have brought them that's in way, they've either brought mysterious powers, or they've brought mysterious technology or ways of, say, constructing mines. In this case, the argument is that Solomon and the Phoenicians together are working to build the temple, and they go to a place called Ophir or Ophet. And basically in King Solomon's mind, Ophir is
那种认为有失落的文明正等待被发现的理念，而且……这与亚特兰蒂斯非常相似，我们在亚特兰蒂斯的话题中讨论过这一点，即如果在非洲发现了废墟和古代文明，人们的假设是它们实际上并非非洲本土起源，是的，而是外来者带来的。在某种程度上，要么是他们带来了神秘的力量，要么是他们带来了神秘的技术或建造矿井的方法。在这种情况下，论点是所罗门和腓尼基人共同努力建造了神庙，他们去了一个叫做俄斐（Ophir）或奥费特的地方。基本上在《所罗门王的宝藏》中，俄斐被
identified with Kukwana land. But in the Bible, Tom, doesn't it say Solomon received tribute of gold, peacocks, cedar wood stuff, yeah, general stuff from this place that has never been pinned down. And people were always, all through the medieval period, people were fascinated by the idea that there was some lost kingdom out there, which was the real Ophir or Ophet. And this place must be incredibly rich. And that sort of became conflated with the other idea, massively popular in medieval period, that there was a lost Christian king out there. Called Prestijon. Called Prestijon, which was clearly based on some garbled memory of Abyssinia, of Ethiopia. But there's also one other kind of Solomonic element, which is the Queen of Sheba.
认作是库库纳兰。但在《圣经》中，汤姆，难道不是说所罗门从这个从未被准确定位的地方收到了黄金、孔雀、雪松木等贡品，也就是一般的物品吗？在整个中世纪，人们一直对这样一种想法着迷：那里存在着某个失落的王国，也就是真正的俄斐或奥费特。这个地方一定极其富有。这种想法后来与另一种在中世纪极为流行的观点融合在了一起——即那里存在着一个失落的基督教国王。名叫普雷斯特·约翰。名叫普雷斯特·约翰，这显然是基于对阿比西尼亚（埃塞俄比亚）的一些混淆的记忆。但还有一个索罗门式的元素，那就是示巴女王。
Yes. And basically, everyone knew where Sheba was. It's Southern Arabia. But increasingly in the Middle Ages, people don't want to be satisfied with that. And they start thinking, where else could it be? And because Africa to Europeans is unknown, it's unmapped, people start thinking that in some way, Prestigion and Ophir and Sheba are somehow kind of blended and are to be found in the depths of Africa. So I mean, this goes right the way back to the 16th century when the Portuguese are starting to really go up river and they're basically the only Europeans to do it. So in 1552, there was this guy called Jao de Barros, who wrote a whole book in which he conflates Prestigion and the
是的。基本上，每个人都知道示巴在哪里。它在阿拉伯南部。但在中世纪，人们越来越不满足于此。他们开始思考，它还能在哪里？由于欧洲人对非洲一无所有、未被测绘，人们开始认为，某种程度上，普雷斯特·约翰、俄斐和示巴在某种程度上被融合了，并且可以在非洲腹地找到。所以我的意思是，这一直可以追溯到16世纪，当时葡萄牙人开始真正逆流而上，他们基本上是唯一这样做的欧洲人。因此在1552年，有一个叫若昂·德·巴罗斯（Jao de Barros）的人，写了一整本书，在书中他将普雷斯特·约翰和
Queen of Sheba and says that there is a ruined city in the middle of Africa. And this proves to be an incredibly potent idea. And over the centuries that follow, people keep looking for it. And then for Ryder Haggard, the key thing is that in 1871, an explorer called Karl Mauch, is it? Karl Mauch? I think it's Karl Mauch, isn't it? But Karl Mauch, he discovers a spectacular ruined city. But that's the thing, Tom.
示巴女王混为一谈，并声称非洲中部有一座废弃的城市。事实证明这是一个极具影响力的概念。在随后的几个世纪里，人们一直在寻找它。然后对于赖德·哈格德来说，关键在于1871年，一个名叫卡尔·莫奇（Karl Mauch）的探险家，是吗？卡尔·莫奇？我想是卡尔·莫奇，对吧？卡尔·莫奇发现了一座壮观的废墟城市。但这就是关键所在，汤姆。
People have been talking about, is there a ruined city in the middle of Africa, a medieval city for hundreds of years? And there is. There is. And this is Great Zimbabwe, which dates back to the 9th century. And as you said, Karl Mauck finds it. I think it had been found by,
人们一直在谈论，非洲中部是否有一座废墟城市，一座中世纪的城市，已经谈论了数百年。确实有。确实有。这就是大津巴布韦，其历史可追溯至9世纪。正如你所说，卡尔·莫奇发现了它。我想它被……
there's another German guy who'd found it a few years earlier, but he takes Karl Mauck and Mauck popularises it, doesn't he? Yeah. And so this is happening um a decade or so before Ryder Haggard starts work on King Solomon's Mines and can I read you what Karl Mauck said about what he found there do okay so he he's writing here the tones of a sober and measured archaeologist it can be taken as a fact that the wood which we obtained from Great Zimbabwe actually is cedar wood, and from this that it
几年前还有另一个德国人发现过它，但他带上了卡尔·莫奇，而莫奇将其大众化了，不是吗？是的。所以这发生在赖德·哈格德开始创作《所罗门王的宝藏》大约十年前，我可以读给你听卡尔·莫奇对他在那里发现的东西的描述吗？好的。所以他在这里写道，带着一个冷静、审慎的考古学家的语气：“可以确认为事实的是，我们从大津巴布韦获得的木材实际上是雪松木，由此可知它
cannot come from anywhere else but from the Lebanon. Furthermore, only the Phoenicians could have brought it here. So that's the level of evidence. I mean, people now read this and they say, my gosh, this is pure imperialism. European observers just could not get their heads around the idea that people in what is now Zimbabwe could have built a medieval city because they didn't think Africans were capable of it. So they had to invent all these sort of ideas that people had travelled ridiculously long distances and established Phoenician colonies in South Africa or whatever. Yeah. I mean, it's clearly racist. It's clearly founded on the idea that Africans can't produce their own civilization.
不可能来自别的任何地方，只能来自黎巴嫩。此外，只有腓尼基人才可能把它带到这里。”这就是证据的水平。我的意思是，人们现在读到这些会说，天哪，这纯粹是帝国主义。欧洲观察家根本无法接受这样一个概念：现在被称为津巴布韦的地方的人民能够建造一座中世纪的城市，因为他们认为非洲人没有这种能力。所以他们必须编造所有这些荒谬的想法，说什么人们长途跋涉了不可思议的距离，在南非建立了腓尼基殖民地等等。是的。我的意思是，这显然是种族主义。它显然建立在非洲人无法创造自己的文明这一观点之上。
But it is also, I think, expressive of a desire to join this beautiful to Europeans exotic land of adventure to reference points that they will understand. And so that's basically, in King Solomon's minds, the Homeric. So there's a kind of great war is fought in Kukuanaland, and it's described in very overtly Homeric terms. The Viking. So one of the heroes in King Solomon's mind, like Haggard himself, is a Viking descent. So Henry, he's often described, isn't he, with his big hair and his beard and his enormous muscles. Haggard absolutely has enormous physical enthusiasm, shall we say. Well, he absolutely does. And so this figure, what's he called? Sir Henry Curtis?
但我也认为，它表达了一种渴望：将这片对欧洲人而言美丽而充满异国情调的冒险土地，与他们能够理解的参照点联系起来。所以这基本上就是《所罗门王的宝藏》中的荷马色彩。库库纳兰发生了一场大战，它是用非常明显的荷马史诗般的语调来描述的。还有维京色彩。所以《所罗门王的宝藏》中的英雄之一，就像哈格德本人一样，是维京后裔。亨利爵士，人们经常这样描述他，不是吗，有着一头浓密的头发、胡须和健硕的肌肉。哈格德对纯粹的体能有着极大的热情，我们可以这么说。嗯，他确实如此。所以这个人物，他叫什么名字？亨利·柯蒂斯爵士？
Sir Henry Curtis, yeah. Sir Henry Curtis joins up with the Zulu guy who we described at the beginning, who has been accompanying them as a servant. But when they arrive there, turns out to be the rightful king of Kokoana land, Ignozi. He's Aragorn, basically, isn't he, Tom? He is Aragorn. And he and Sir Henry both dress up in the same kind of war gear, and Rhyde Haggard is very, very keen on it. The dress was no doubt a savage one, but I am bound to say I never saw a finer sight than Sir Henry Curtis presented in this guise. It showed off his magnificent physique to the greatest advantage. And when Ignosi arrived presently arrayed in cinema costume, I thought to myself that I never before saw two such splendid men. And I think the thing there is the idea that Ignosi is part of a culture in Ryder Haggard's
亨利·柯蒂斯爵士，是的。亨利·柯蒂斯爵士与我们在开头描述的那位一直陪伴他们作为仆人的祖鲁人联合起来。但当他们到达那里时，结果证明他是库库纳兰的合法国王——伊格诺西（Ignozi）。他基本上就是阿拉贡，对吧，汤姆？他就是阿拉贡。他和亨利爵士都穿着同一种战地装备，赖德·哈格德对此非常、非常热衷：“毫无疑问，这种服饰带有野蛮色彩，但我不得不说，我从未见过比亨利·柯蒂斯爵士以这种装扮呈现的更棒的景象了。它以极大的优势展现了他那宏伟的体魄。当伊格诺西随后身着电影服装（注：原文cinematime应为某种服饰或盛装，此处暂译）到来时，我心想，我以前从未见过两个如此出众的男子。”我认为其中的关键在于，伊格诺西是赖德·哈格德笔下某种文化的一部分
view that is still on a level with Vikings and with Homeric Greeks. And Sir Henry Curtis, by going there, has been able to reclaim his own status as someone equivalent in a way that he would never have done had he stayed in his ancestral estate back in England. Yeah, I think that's absolutely right. He has this idea, which I think is enormously potent. And actually, you can see in all kinds of popular culture today, this idea that by going to Africa, you will somehow turn the clock back, cast off the degeneracy of modern life and become more truly authentic. But also going back to Haggard and Great Zimbabwe, just before we go to the break, Haggard wrote a preface to a history of Great guzman barbara of this site he he absolutely
这种观点依然停留在维京人和荷马时代希腊人的水平。而亨利·柯蒂斯爵士通过去到那里，得以重新确立了他作为同等级别人物的地位，如果他留在英国祖传的庄园里，这是他永远无法做到的。是的，我认为这绝对没错。他有这样一种想法，我认为这种想法极具影响力。事实上，你可以在今天各种流行文化中看到这种观点：通过去往非洲，你将以某种方式让时光倒流，摆脱现代生活的堕落，变得更加真正地真实。但同样，在回到海格德和大津巴布韦之前，在我们休息一下之前，海格德为该遗址的一本历史书写了一篇前言，他绝对
believed that it was phoenician i mean what would strike us as just an absolutely ludicrous bonkers idea sort of netflix worthy tom i think it's fair to say and haggard said um what was the condition of this empire and what the measure of the effective dignity of its emperor points rather difficult to determine i mean which, which is putting it mildly. But then he says, it is legitimate to hope, it seems probable even, that in centuries to come, a town will once more nestle beneath these grey and ancient ruins, trading in gold, as did that of the Phoenicians, but peopled by men of the Anglo-saxon race well and in fact that kind of does happen because in 1890 the region that um the great zimbabwe is standing in place called mashona land is occupied by um cecil roads
坚信它是腓尼基的。我的意思是，在我们的眼中，这绝对是一个荒谬绝伦的想法，汤姆，可以说是非常具有网飞（Netflix）改编的价值，我想这么说并不过分。海格德说：“这个帝国的状况如何，其皇帝的实际尊严的尺度如何，这些都相当难以确定。”——我的意思是，这话说得已经很委婉了。但接着他说：“我们有理由希望，甚至似乎很有可能，在未来的几个世纪里，一个城镇将再次依偎在这些灰色而古老的废墟之下，像腓尼基人那样进行黄金贸易，但居住在那里的人将是盎格鲁-萨克逊人种。”嗯，事实上，这种事确实发生了，因为在1890年，大津巴布韦所在的那个被称为马绍纳兰的地区被塞西尔·罗兹的
british south africa company and roads becomes absolutely obsessed with the idea that that zimbabwe was phoenician and he sets up a company, which is brilliantly called Rhodesia Ancient Ruins Limited, which claimed the exclusive tourist rights to it. And of course, Rhodesia, Meshonaland gets given Rhodes' name and Rhodesia will become a kind of white settler country. So exactly. So in some ways, Haggard got what he wanted because of course, gold was one of the things that was driving the British deeper and deeper into Africa. Listen, we should take a break, Tom. There's so much to just, I mean, it's such a fascinating subject. There's so much to unpack. And we shall return after the break with talk of explorers, big game hunters.
英国南非公司占领了，罗兹对津巴布韦是腓尼基人建立的这种想法变得极其着迷。他成立了一家公司，名字起得非常妙，叫“罗得西亚古代遗址有限公司”（Rhodesia Ancient Ruins Limited），该公司声称拥有该遗址的独家旅游权。当然，罗得西亚、马绍纳兰被冠以罗兹的名字，而罗得西亚也将成为一种白人定居者国家。所以，确实如此。从某种意义上说，海格德如愿以偿了，因为黄金当然是驱使英国人更深、更深地深入非洲的动因之一。听着，我们该休息一下了，汤姆。有太多的话要说——我的意思是，这是一个如此迷人的主题，有太多的内容需要剖析。休息过后，我们将回归，谈谈探险家和大猎场看守人。
But also for any female listeners thinking this is all a bit masculine, we will also be discussing Ryder Haggard's attitude to the ladies. Exactly. We're like Mitt Romney. We've got binders full of women. And we'll be back after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
但对于任何觉得这一切都有点太大男子主义的女性听众，我们也将讨论莱德·海格德对女性的态度。没错。我们就像米特·罗姆尼（Mitt Romney）。我们有一抽屉的女性资料。我们休息一下，一会儿回来。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. For there, not more than 40 or 50 miles from us,
我们共同主持《娱乐至上》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、额外单集以及抢先获得现场门票的福利，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。因为在那里，离我们不超过40或50英里处，
glittering like silver in the early rays of the morning sun, were Sheba's breasts. And stretching away for hundreds of miles on each side of them was the great Solomon Berg. Now that I, sitting here, attempt to describe the extraordinary grandeur and beauty of that site, language seems to fail me. I am impotent, even before its memory. There, straight before us, were two enormous mountains, the like of which are not, I believe, to be seen in Africa, if indeed there are any other such in the world, measuring each at least fifteen thousand feet in height, standing not more than a dozen miles apart, connected by a precipitous cliff of rock, and towering up in awful white solemnity straight into the sky.
在清晨阳光的微光中像银子一样闪闪发光的就是“示巴女王的乳房”。在它们两侧绵延数百英里的是巨大的所罗门山脉。现在，我坐在这里，试图描述那个遗址无与伦比的宏伟与美丽时，语言似乎背叛了我。甚至在回忆它时，我也显得无能为力。就在我们正前方，矗立着两座巨大的山脉，我相信在非洲是见不到这样的山脉的，如果世界上确实还有其他这样的山脉的话。它们的每一座高度至少有1.5万英里（应为英尺），彼此相距不过十几英里，由一道险峻的岩壁相连，以一种令人敬畏的白色庄严直插云霄。
These mountains standing thus, like the pillars of a gigantic gateway, are shaped exactly like a woman's breasts. Their bases swelled gently up from the plain, looking at that distance, perfectly round and smooth, and on the top of each was a vast round hillock covered with snow, exactly corresponding to the nipple on the female breast. So, Dominic, deep waters. I mean, frankly, one of the weirdest passages in the whole of Victorian literature. And the weird thing is that Ryder Haggardard makes a boast doesn't he of there being no petticoats in king solomon's minds and he says the kind of the opening introduction that it is
这两座山峰像巨大门户的柱子一样巍然耸立，其形状完全像女性的乳房。它们的山脚从平原上平缓地隆起，从那个距离看，显得极其圆润平滑，每座山的山顶都有一个被雪覆盖的巨大圆形小山丘，完全对应着女性乳房上的乳头。所以，多米尼克，水很深啊。坦白说，这可以说是维基利亚文学中最诡异的段落之一。诡异的是，莱德·海格德在《所罗门王的宝藏》中曾夸耀过里面没有女性（petticoats），他在开篇的引言中说，这本书
dedicated to all the big and little boys who read it yes and yet actually a kind of nervousness about the female is is present throughout the book. There are some very deep waters here, Tom. Right, so there are a couple of things here. So one is that Haggard is like so many imperial writers. He is absolutely obsessed with the idea of masculine brotherhood, isn't he? Yes. And manliness.
献给所有阅读它的或大或小的男孩们。是的，然而事实上，书中自始至终都弥漫着一种对女性的焦虑。这里的水真的很深，汤姆。好吧，这里有几个要点。首先，海格德就像许多帝国作家一样，他绝对迷恋男性兄弟情谊的想法，不是吗？是的。还有男子气概。
So he believes that you'll become more manly by going to Africa, but it's also incredibly important that your manliness is connected to other men. So the idea of the fellowship, the brotherhood, which obviously Tolkien then copied, critics describe it as homosocial, don't they? Rather than homoerotic. But the way he talks about Sir Henry
所以他认为，通过去非洲，你会变得更有男子气概，但同样极其重要的是，你的男子气概必须与其他男性相连。因此，这种伙伴关系、兄弟情谊的概念——托尔金后来显然对此进行了效仿——评论家们将其描述为“同性社交”（homosocial），对吧？而不是“同性恋”（homoerotic）。但他谈论亨利爵士的方式——
with his rippling muscles and all this sort of stuff, there is an awful lot going on there. And that is actually very common among not just imperial writers, but all these imperial characters, General Gordon, Kitchener, Lord Milner, all of these people. It was all about kind of strapping young men common among not just imperial writers but all these imperial characters general gordon kitchener yeah lord milner all of these people it was all about kind of strapping young men you know
伴随着他起伏的肌肉和诸如此类的种种描写，其中暗含的东西实在太多了。而这实际上不仅在帝国作家中非常普遍，在所有这些帝国人物中也是如此——戈登将军、基辛格（应为基奇纳）、米尔纳勋爵，所有这些人。这一切都关乎那种健美的年轻男子——不仅在帝国作家中非常普遍，在所有这些帝国人物中也是如此——戈登将军、基辛格（应为基奇纳）、是的，米尔纳勋爵，所有这些人。这一切都关乎那种健美的年轻男子，你知道的，
stripping off together and and stuff the the corollary of that is a certain nervousness about uh about women definitely so yeah i mean i don't think you'd have to be freud to recognize that in a way the whole journey is is a kind of trip across africa represented as a female body so yeah the breasts i mean literally she the queen of sheba's breasts and then they go into this beautiful kind of paradisal land and then they go deep underground into the tunnels and they get trapped there yes they can't get out there's a lot going on there and they get trapped there by the most memorable character in the whole book yeah who is this witch called gagool who is i mean fabulously ancient and when i say fabulous i mean literally so because i mentioned how they have the whole thing the stunt with the eclipse and things and
大家一起赤裸着身子之类的。与之对应的结果，就是对女性的一种某种程度的焦虑——绝对如此。所以，是的——我的意思是，你不需要成为弗洛伊德也能认出，某种程度上，整个旅程就像是一次穿越非洲的旅行，而非洲被具象化为一个女性的身体。所以，是的，乳房——字面意义上的，示巴女王的乳房——然后他们进入了这样一个美丽的天堂般的土地，然后他们深入地下隧道，并被困在那里。是的，他们出不去，里面发生了太多的事情。他们被书中令人印象深刻的角色困在了那里。是的，这个女巫叫加古尔（Gagool），她——我的意思是，她有着神话般的古老年龄。当我说“神话般”时，我指的是字面意思，因为我提到过他们如何用日食之类的把戏来完成整件事，以及
how this is impresses everybody with their ability to to kind of command deep magic. But Gagul is not impressed because she has already seen this happen, which implies that she is literally centuries old. Catherine Rundell in her essay in the LRB says that Ryder Haggard is obviously obsessed with monkeys because she is described as a monkey. and people who are so old that they've basically become like monkeys are a feature throughout rider haggard's fiction that's right so giggle by the way we mentioned tolkien i think giggle is i mean giggle is very golem like she kind of capers around like a monkey golem's often described as a monkey she's wizened and kind of wrinkled and it's as though by living so long, she has... She's become stretched.
这如何以他们能够掌控高深魔法的能力给每个人留下深刻印象。但加古尔并没有被震撼，因为她以前已经见过这种事了，这意味着她字面意义上已经活了几个世纪。凯瑟琳·鲁德尔（Catherine Rundell）在《伦敦书评》（LRB）的文章中说，莱德·海格德显然对猴子有着狂热的执念，因为她被描述为一只猴子。而那些老到基本上变得像猴子一样的人，是莱德·海格德小说中的一个特色。没错，所以加古尔——顺便说一句，我们提到了托尔金——我认为加古尔非常像咕噜（Gollum）。她像猴子一样蹦蹦跳跳，咕噜也经常被描述为猴子。她枯槁且满脸皱纹，就好像活了这么久，她已经……她被拉长了。
She has. She's become stretched. And she's kind of degenerated into something that's not entirely human. And now, obviously, there are all kinds of things going on here. So she's a version of... She's a woman. She's also obviously... You know, she's black.
是的。她被拉长了。她退化成了一种不完全是人类的东西。现在，很显然，这里面发生了各种各样的事情。所以她是某种版本的……她是一个女人。同时她显然也是……你知道的，她是黑人。
She's African. And there's all kinds of weird stuff going on in Haggard's mind. There is another woman called Fulata. She's a kind of love interest. So she has to die. She's killed. Yeah, she's very pretty and she dies.
她是非洲人。在海格德的脑海里，充斥着各种各样诡异的想法。还有一个叫富拉塔（Fulata）的女人。她算是一个爱情线的人物。所以她必须死。她被杀了。是的，她非常漂亮，然后她死了。
And Alan Quatermain, now she's become obsessed with one of his travelling companions who is Captain Good. Who spends the whole time walking around without trousers on.
而艾伦·夸特曼——现在她迷恋上了他的一个同行旅伴，也就是古德船长（Captain Good）。
She's obsessed. All the characters are obsessed with his legs. And it's clear that she and Good are a couple or are going to become a couple. And so when she dies, Alan Quatermain says,
古德整天光着裤子走来走去。她迷恋上了。所有角色都对他的腿着迷。很显然，她和古德是一对，或者说即将成为一对。因此，当她死后，艾伦·夸特曼说：
I feel bound to say that I consider her removal a fortunate occurrence since otherwise complications would have been sure to ensue in other words you can't shack up with an african woman right but and but the complications in haggard's mind are not just social they're biological right because this is an age when racism is scientifically based increasingly. Yes, absolutely. And there's quite a lot of that in Ryder Haggard's novels. So the masculine brotherhood and the idea of becoming more truly yourself when you're out with your friends, your male friends in Africa,
“我不得不说，我认为她的离去是一件幸运的事，否则接下来必然会引发种种复杂的状况。”换句话说，你不能和一个非洲女人同居，对吧？但是——但是海格德心里的复杂状况不仅是社会的，还是生物学的，对吧？因为这是一个种族主义越来越多地建立在科学基础上的时代。是的，绝对是的。在莱德·海格德的小说中，有相当多这样的内容。因此，男性的兄弟情谊，以及这种想法：当你和你的朋友们——你的男性朋友们——在非洲时，你会变得更加真实的自我，
hunting elephants and having adventures, that goes hand in hand with this idea that back home in the cities surrounded by all the trappings of kind of urban industrial modernity the race is becoming degenerate that the white race this is the word terminology haggard would have used is losing its kind of vital sap and all of this stuff and this fear of degenerate of racial degeneracy runs right through i mean it's not just haggard but so much of the kind of culture of the 1880s, 1890s, 1900s. So every British defeat, but that defeat against the Zulus, the defeat in the First Boer War,
狩猎大象，经历冒险。这与另一种想法密不可分：回到国内的城市，被城市工业现代性的各种表象所包围，种族正在走向堕落——白人种族（这是海格德会使用的术语）正在失去其某种至关重要的生命力，诸如此类。这种对退化、对种族堕落的恐惧贯穿始终——我的意思是，不仅是海格德，18世纪80年代、90年代以及20世纪00年代的大多数文化都是如此。因此，每一次英国的战败——比如对祖鲁人的战败，第一次布尔战争中的战败，
and then later on much more so in the Second Boer War, they're all explained by the fact that people say, well, what do you expect? All these people work in factories and they live in the cities. They don't hunt elephants. They become racially degenerate. And this is is now the character who epitomizes this the woman character is the the person from haggard's other big bestseller and that is she and that's another quest so we don't have time to kind of go into all the details of that but basically the lead
以及后来在第二次布尔战争中的惨败——都可以用人们所说的事实来解释：好吧，你还能指望什么呢？这些人都在工厂工作，生活在城市里。他们不捕杀大象。他们种族堕落了。而现在，这个完美体现这一点的角色——女性角色——正是海格德另一部畅销书中的人物，也就是《她》（She），那是另一场探险。所以我们没有时间深入探讨其中的所有细节，但基本上，主角
character and she is like a combination of gagu and and Fulata. And she's basically... So she's very beautiful, but thousands of years old because she's maintained the secret of eternal youth, but is an incredible witch. Yes. So she's Aisha. I mean, she's one of the dominating female characters in, I would say, in all popular fiction. She gets the name that was given to Ryder Haggard's rag doll
在《她》中就像是加古尔和富拉塔的结合体。她基本上……她非常美丽，但却有数千年的历史，因为她掌握了长生不老的秘密，同时又是一个不可思议的女巫。是的。所以她就是阿伊莎（Aisha）。我的意思是，我认为她是所有通俗小说中最具统治力的女性角色之一。她得到了那个名字——这个名字来自莱德·海格德童年时期的布娃娃，
from his childhood, She Who Must Be Obeyed, and which in the Rumpel books, uh, Rumpel, that's right. His wife, she, who must be obeyed.
叫做“必须服从的她”（She Who Must Be Obeyed），而在《伦普尔》系列书籍中，呃，伦普尔，没错。他的妻子，“必须服从的她”。
So, um, so if you read, she, I mean, she is an intoxicating book. It's very, I mean,
所以，嗯，如果你读过《她》，我的意思是，这是一本令人陶醉的书。这非常——
it's hard not to read it with your kind of Freudian hat on, isn't it? Tom Catherine Rundell had something very funny to say about Aisha though, because she subjects the characters who've gone on this quest at colossally long monologues. She says she rants like nigel farage and has only one point to make men are powerless in the face of beautiful women for women desire not men but power the greatest woman to have ever lived is a disappointment a heckling sex witch that's basically what um what happens to uh to the characters they just
很难不带着你的弗洛伊德滤镜去阅读它，不是吗？汤姆？不过，凯瑟琳·鲁德尔对阿伊莎有一些非常有趣的评价，因为她对进行这场探险的角色们进行了冗长得令人发指的独白。她说她像奈杰尔·法拉奇（Nigel Farage）一样狂怒咆哮，而且只有一个观点：在美丽的女人面前，男人是无能为力的，因为女人渴望的不是男人，而是权力。有史以来最伟大的女性却是一个令人失望的、爱起哄的性爱女巫。这基本上就是——那些角色们的遭遇，他们只是
are forced to listen to Aisha for all this time. But then at the end, there's more sort of this weird kind of degeneracy stuff because she bathes in this sort of the fountain of life and she shrivels in the flames
被迫听阿伊莎讲了这么长时间的话。但随后在最后，又出现了一些这种诡异的堕落情节，因为她在生命之泉中沐浴，却在火焰中枯萎，
and literally turns into a kind of like a little wrinkled monkey before she dies. So this again, I mean, there's all kinds of stuff going on there with the kind of the undercurrents of of the imperial mentality i suppose you would say well yeah because um vm v is pritchett writing about um she said that um wrote mr em forster once spoke of the novelist sending down a bucket into the unconscious. The author of She installed a suction pump. I mean, it's so, it's very, very right. But She, I mean, She is the primary text of the Lost World genre.
在死前字面意义上变成了一只皱巴巴的小猴子。所以这又一次——我的意思是，其中充斥着各种各样关于帝国心态潜流的东西，我想你会这么说。嗯，是的，因为——弗里奇特（V.S. Pritchett）在谈到《她》时曾说：“M·福斯特先生（E.M. Forster）曾经说过，小说家将水桶放入无意识的深井中。而《她》的作者则安装了一台吸水泵。”我的意思是，这真的——非常准确。但《她》——《她》是“失落世界”流派的核心文本。
In Brian Aldiss's history of science fiction, his kind of definitive canonical history of science fiction, he says, She creates this idea of the empress, the priestess, the sorceress that is at the heart of so many scientific romances. So you go to an alien planet and it's ruled by this terrifying, sexy, but deeply evil woman. I mean, that is pure Ryder Haggard. I mean, going even deeper into the subconscious, is there a sense in which Ryder Haggard is expressing something in the fact that she is published in 1887, which is the year of Queen Victoria's Golden Jubilee, and Aisha is a reclusive white queen ruling over Africans, and so is Queen Victoria? Is there some sense? Lots of critics say this. Lots of post-colonial critics and whatnot are very interested in this.
在布赖恩·奥尔迪斯（Brian Aldiss）的科幻小说史——他那种权威的科幻小说正统历史中，他说：《她》创造了女皇、女祭司、女巫的形象，而这正是众多科学浪漫小说（scientific romances）的核心。所以当你去到一个外星球时，它是由这个可怕的、性感的，但又极其邪恶的女人统治的。我的意思是，这纯粹是莱德·海格德式的。我的意思是，更深入地探究潜意识，有没有这样一种感觉：莱德·海格德在某种程度上表达了一些东西，鉴于《她》出版于1887年——也就是维多利亚女王金禧庆典的那一年——而阿伊莎是一个隐居的、统治着非洲人的白人女王，维多利亚女王不也是如此吗？有没有这种感觉？许多评论家都这么说。许多后殖民主义评论家之流对这一点非常感兴趣。
And they say it's his own anxieties or Britain's anxieties about its own empire, about its legitimacy. What do you think? Well, you know, I can be a bit sceptical. So there's part of me that says, yeah, it's probably a coincidence. I don't think so, because I think the whole idea of white queens is so associated with Victoria. And even if he's not consciously doing it to make this villain the white queen. Well, she actually says, Aisha says, I'm going to go back to Britain with you, topple your queen, who's obviously useless, and become queen myself.
他们说，这是他自己的焦虑，或者是英国对自身帝国、对其合法性的焦虑。你觉得呢？嗯，你知道的，我可能会有点怀疑。所以我的内心有一部分会说：是的，这可能只是个巧合。我不这么认为，因为我认为白人女王的概念与维多利亚联系得太紧密了。即使他不是有意识地把这个反派塑造为白人女王——嗯，事实上她说过，阿伊莎说：“我要和你们一起回英国，推翻你们那位显然毫无用处的女王，由我自己来当女王。”
So, you know, maybe there is stuff going on there. There are a couple of other themes, I think, that we should talk about. So one is, obviously, these are books of an age of exploration. So Burton and Speak, Richard Burton and John Hanning Speak, a couple of decades earlier, had gone on these amazing expeditions to discover the African Great Lakes in the heart of Africa. Henry Morton Stanley, most famously, had found Livingston in 1872, and his book on Livingston had been a massive, massive hit. And this idea of this fascination with maps that you get both in She and in King Solomon's Minds, I mean, that's absolutely of
所以，你知道的，也许里面确实有些名堂。我认为我们还应该讨论另外几个主题。首先，很明显，这些都是探索时代的书籍。所以伯顿和斯皮克（Burton and Speake，理查德·伯顿和约翰·汉宁·斯皮克）在几十年前曾进行过这些惊人的探险，去发现非洲心脏地带的非洲大湖。亨利·莫顿·斯坦利（Henry Morton Stanley）最著名的事迹是在1872年找到了利文斯顿，他关于利文斯顿的书获得了巨大的成功。这种对地图的痴迷——你在《她》和《索罗门王的宝藏》中都能感受到——我的意思是，这绝对是
the age. So people love the idea of what Joseph Conrad talks about later on in The Heart of Darkness. And there's two ideas at once. One that africa is the heart of darkness that by going deeper into africa you penetrate into this sort of world of primeval wickedness i mean that's obviously very common in imperial mentality of the 19th century yeah so stopping slavery and and witchcraft right but also the the idea of blank spaces. There's a few blank spaces left and who knows what's there. But again, there is this tension. So if Africa is a land where the savagery is expressed through slavery and witchcraft, at the same time, it is a land where we talked before, where lost wisdom may be found, a
那个时代的产物。所以人们喜欢约瑟夫·康拉德后来在《黑暗的心》（The Heart of Darkness）中所谈论的那种概念。这里同时存在着两种观念。一种观念是，非洲是黑暗的心脏，通过深入非洲，你就能进入这个原始邪恶的世界——这在19世纪的帝国心态中显然非常普遍。是的，所以要制止奴隶制和巫术——但同时也有“空白地带”的概念。还剩下一些空白地带，谁知道那里有什么呢。但同样地，这里存在着一种紧张关系。因此，如果非洲是一片通过奴隶制和巫术表现出野蛮行径的土地，与此同时，它也是一块我们之前谈到的、能够找到失落智慧的土地，一种
kind of primal freshness that warriors are braver bolder stronger i mean so there's a kind of tension there isn't there that is i suppose if you're writing novels it results in you not just writing kind of racist propaganda yeah i mean there clearly is enthusiasm for the british empire inder Haggard's books, and there is definitely quite a deep strain of racism there. But it's not just racist. It's not just imperial. It kind of reaps narrative fruit from those tensions. It does.
原始的清新，那里的勇士更加勇敢、更大胆、更强大——所以这里存在着一种紧张关系，不是吗？我想，如果你在写小说，这种紧张关系的结果就是你写出来的不仅是种族主义宣传。是的——我的意思是，在莱德·海格德的书中的确存在着对大英帝国的热情，而且其中绝对有着相当深厚的种族主义色彩。但它不仅是种族主义的，也不仅仅是帝国的。它从这些紧张关系中收获了叙事果实。确实如此。
Because as you said, he regards the character of Ignacy in King Solomon's Minds, let's say, as noble, as impressive. And actually, at the end of the book, I mean, spoiler alert, Ignacy, surprise, surprise, regains his kingdom. But he explicitly says to the heroes, no white man other than you may ever come into my kingdom. You know, I know all you want is diamonds and gold. We won't have you. We won't have missionaries. We won't have people selling rum, you know, all of this sort of stuff.
因为正如你所说，他在《索罗门王的宝藏》中将伊格纳西（Ignosi）这个角色视为高贵的、令人印象深刻的。事实上，在书的结尾——剧透预警——伊格纳西（不出所料）重新夺回了他的王国。但他明确地对英雄们说：“除了你们之外，任何白人都不准进入我的王国。我知道你们想要的只是钻石和黄金。我们不欢迎你们。我们不要传教士。我们不要贩卖朗姆酒的人——诸如此类的一切。”
That shows that Haggard is aware of the costs of empire and of what an African king would say about it. Again, spoiler alert, as you said, there are other missions. So Ignatius gets his kingdom. So Henry Curtis does find his brother. But actually, the quest for King Solomon's mines turns out to be a bit of a dud because essentially, many of the characters are not interested in the diamonds. Alan Quatermain is. I mean, he scoops up loads of diamonds and becomes ends up very rich and is made unhappy by it goes back to england builds it has an estate and is left kind of restless and and unhappy but so henry curtis doesn't take any any diamonds at all and throughout the book the obsession of europeans with diamonds and gold is relentlessly criticized really it is
这表明海格德意识到了帝国的代价，以及一个非洲国王会对它说些什么。再次剧透预警，正如你所说，还有其他的任务。因此伊格纳西得到了他的王国。亨利·柯蒂斯爵士确实找到了他的兄弟。但事实上，寻找所罗门王宝藏的任务结果证明有点像个烂尾工程，因为基本上，许多角色对钻石并不感兴趣。艾伦·夸特曼是的。我的意思是，他搜刮了大量的钻石，最后变得非常富有，却因此感到痛苦，于是回到了英国，建立了一座庄园，最终变得焦躁不安且不快乐。但是——亨利·柯蒂斯一颗钻石也没有拿，而且在整本书中，欧洲人对钻石和黄金的痴迷受到了毫不留情的批判。真的吗？是的。
i mean the fascinating thing about haggard and it's actually of so many of these imperial writers, Kipling, I think, is very similar, is that he's too good a writer to be just a racist propagandist. To be jingoistic, yeah. But when he's not writing novels, he's incredibly jingoistic. He writes again and again, kind of letters to the Times and things, saying, so in 1913, he says, the future of Africa will not be a conflict between the Britons and the Boers, but the inevitable, though let us hope, far-off struggle for practical supremacy between the white blood and the black. And he's always saying this stuff. 1924, in his diary, the great ultimate war, as I've always held, will be that between the white and coloured races. And that history will ultimately be the story of the bloody conflict
我的意思是，关于海格德最迷人的地方——其实许多这样的帝国作家都是如此，我认为吉卜林（Kipling）与他非常相似——在于他是一位太优秀的出色作家，不能仅仅被称为一个种族主义宣传家。也就是沙文主义者，是的。但当他不写小说时，他极其具有沙文主义色彩。他一次又一次地给《泰晤士报》之类的地方写信，比如在1913年，他说：“非洲的未来不会是英国人和布尔人之间的冲突，而是白人血统与黑人血统之间不可避免的、尽管我们希望还很遥远的争夺实际统治权的斗争。”他总是说这些话。1924年，在他的日记中写道：“正如我一直认为的那样，最终的伟大战争将是白人与有色人种之间的战争。而历史最终将是不可调和对立的种族之间血腥冲突的故事。”
between implacably opposed races. But I suppose the tension there is that he's not taking for granted who would win a war between the black and the white races, because his anxiety would be that the white race is degenerate, and that the black race as a desandwana is braver stronger kind of less corrupted exactly that he talks again and again in his and other writers do as well um about how life is struggle he's a he's a darwin he's a social darwinist a classic social darwinist so he gives this these words to aisha and she in this world none but the strongest can endure those who are weak must perish the earth is to the strong and the fruits thereof um for every tree that grows a score shall wither that the strong may take their
但我想其中的紧张关系在于，他并不认为黑人种族和白人种族之间的战争谁会赢是理所当然的，因为他的焦虑在于白人种族正在退化，而黑人种族——作为一个桑多瓦纳（应为像某种自然原住民）——更加勇敢、更强大、更少被腐蚀。没错——他一再在他的作品中以及其他作家的作品中——谈论生活就是斗争。他是一个达尔文主义者——他是一个社会达尔文主义者，典型的社会达尔文主义者。所以他把这些话赋予了阿伊莎：在这个世界上，只有最强者才能持久，那些虚弱的必将灭亡。大地属于强者，其果实亦然……对于每一棵生长的树，将有二十棵枯萎，以便强者能够拿走他们的
share i mean that's you know it's like something from um nuremberg in the 1920s but this is absolutely what people are saying by the way at the time it's not unusual he's obsessed with the idea that in britain people are they've lost their kind of manliness and and actually the heroes that he likes are not generally traditional imperial figures they are big game hunters explore i mean there's this he's absolutely of that generation that fantasize about these kind of maverick virile sort of eccentric characters so there are two models for alan quatermain so quatermain says at the beginning of the king solomon'sines, I've been trading, hunting, fighting, or mining all my life, which is very Wilbur Smith.
份额。我的意思是，你知道的，这就像是20世纪20年代来自纽伦堡的东西，但这绝对是当时人们所说的话，这并不罕见。他痴迷于这样一个想法：在英国，人们已经失去了他们的男子气概——事实上，他喜欢的英雄通常不是传统的帝国人物，而是大猎场看守人、探险家——我的意思是，他是那一代人中的典型，幻想这些独行侠式的、充满男子气概的、古怪的角色。所以艾伦·夸特曼有两个原型。夸特曼在《索罗门王的宝藏》开篇就说：我一生都在经商、狩猎、战斗或采矿，这非常像威尔伯·史密斯（Wilbur Smith）。
But the real-life inspirations for Quatermain, there are two of them. One is a guy called Frederick Sellers, who was an explorer and big-game hunter from the 1870s onwards. He is an amazing character, actually. He'd never be big enough, I think, for the rest of his history on his own. But when he was 19, Frederick Sellers in 1870, I read, and I quote, he knocked unconscious a Prussian game warden who tackled him while he was stealing buzzard eggs for his collection. And he had to leave the country at once to avoid imprisonment.
但夸特曼在现实生活中的灵感来源有两个。其中一个是叫弗雷德里克·塞勒斯（Frederick Selous）的人，他是一位18世纪70年代及以后的探险家和大猎场看守人。事实上，他是一个了不起的人物。我想，单凭他自己，他的成就还不足以载入他的全部历史。但当他19岁时，1870年的弗雷德里克·塞勒斯——我读到并引用：“他打晕了一位普鲁士的游戏管理员（game warden），当时他正在偷秃鹰蛋来充实他的收藏，而那个人试图制止他。”他不得不立刻离开这个国家以避免入狱。
So he left Prussia. He went off to Africa. He was British. He went off to Africa, ended up working for Cecil Rhodes he shot 78 elephants in three years the Natural History Museum to this day Tom has 524 animals shot by Frederick Sellers including 19 lions
所以他离开了普鲁士。他去了非洲。他是英国人。他去了非洲，最后为塞西尔·罗兹工作。他在三年内射杀了78头大象。汤姆，直到今天，自然历史博物馆里还保存着弗雷德里克·塞勒斯射杀的524只动物，其中包括19头狮子。
wow and he died at the age of 65 fighting the Germans in the First World War in Tanganyika so he's one inspiration for Alan Quatermain and the other is a guy called Joseph Thompson, who was a Scottish geologist and explorer. Here's a nice telling link. He studied under Thomas Huxley, Darwin's bulldog. Ah, yes, right. And he went off to Kenya. He was gored by a buffalo while trying to climb Mount Kilimanjaro.
哇。他在65岁时在坦噶尼喀与德国人作战时牺牲。所以他是艾伦·夸特曼的一个灵感来源，另一个是一个叫约瑟夫·汤姆森（Joseph Thompson）的人，他是一位苏格兰地质学家和探险家。这里有一个很好的说明性联系：他曾在达尔文的“斗牛犬”托马斯·赫胥黎（Thomas Huxley）手下学习。啊，是的，没错。他去了肯尼亚。在试图攀登乞力马扎罗山时，他被一头水牛顶伤了。
Of course he was. Then he works for Cecil Rhodes again, getting concessions and treaties in Rhodesia. And actually, Haggard was accused of plagiarising his book about travels with the Maasai. So all of this stuff is a sort of network of imperial connections and neuroses and anxieties. All this thing about people hunting, people simultaneously admiring and fearing native peoples whom they are displacing and ripping off the sense of a frontier that is slowly closing of course what it reminds you of is the wild west in america yeah and the role that that has played in the the american cultural imagination and there's a sense in which basically africa is is playing that role for british fiction writers i think i hadn't thought
当然他会的。然后他再次为塞西尔·罗兹工作，在罗得西亚获得特许权和条约。事实上，海格德曾被指控抄袭他关于与马赛人一起旅行的书。所以所有这些东西都是一个帝国关系、神经官能症和焦虑的网络。所有关于人们狩猎、人们同时钦佩和恐惧他们正在取代和剥夺的本地土著人民的事情——一种正在慢慢关闭的边境的感觉。当然，这让你想起了美国的狂野西部，
of that but i think that's absolutely right. Now you mention it. It is, isn't it? The idea of hunting, the idea of the Indians in America, the Native Americans as sort of there to be feared, but also respected as, yeah. So obviously the legacy of the Wild West continues right the way into the future.
以及它在美国文化想象中所扮演的角色。在某种程度上，非洲正在为英国的小说作家扮演这个角色。我想我之前没有这样想过，但我认为这绝对是对的。经你这么一提起。确实如此，不是吗？狩猎的概念，美国印第安人的概念——美洲原住民既让人害怕，但也作为某种存在受到尊重，是的。所以很明显，狂野西部的遗产一直延续到了未来。
I mean, everybody is familiar with that. I guess it's more occluded, but the influence of King Solomon's mines and that tradition, I mean, that is also absolutely a part of, I mean, it remains a influence of King Solomon's mines and that tradition, I mean, that is also absolutely a part of, I mean, it remains a part of popular culture to this day, really, would you say? I think it absolutely is. So when Haggard died in the 1920s, the Edinburgh Review, I found this wonderful quote, Haggard's South African romance has filled many a young fellow with longing to go into
我的意思是，每个人都熟悉这一点。我想它可能更隐蔽一些，但《所罗门王的宝藏》及其传统的影响——我的意思是，这也绝对是——我的意思是，它至今仍是流行文化的一部分，你会这么说吗？我认为绝对是。因此，当海格德在20世纪20年代去世时，《爱丁堡评论》（Edinburgh Review）——我找到了这句精彩的引言：“海格德的南非传奇小说让许多年轻小伙子满怀渴望地去到那些广阔的土地，亲自去看看那里的奇观。因此，它们在将英国定居者和影响力引入这片新土地方面，起到了远比我们所能知道的更大的作用。它们帮助实现了塞西尔·罗兹的梦想和目标。”所以我想有两件事。首先，很明显，海格德是两三位伟大的帝国作家之一，比如吉卜林，我想是的。但同时，我认为你刚才提到的那些主题——
the wide spaces of those lands and see their marvels for himself. And they have thus aided far more than we can ever know in bringing British settlers and influence into the new country. They have helped to accomplish the dreams and aims of Cecil Rhodes. So there's two things, I think. One is that obviously Haggard is one of the two or three great writers of empire, like Kipling, I suppose. But also, I think the themes that you've just mentioned you know the things that are similar to the wild west but also the idea of being stuck underground archaeological discoveries lost worlds layers
你知道的，那些与狂野西部相似的东西，还有被困在地下、考古发现、失落的世界、一层又一层被冒险家们发掘的历史、可怕的女巫——所有这些东西。我的意思是，它们自始至终都在那里，不是吗？部分原因我想是因为在海格德生命的尽头，他的作品在好莱坞的第一批冒险电影和有声电影等中被搬上了银幕。所以所有这些人，即使他们从未读过《所罗门王的宝藏》或《她》，所有这些最终在电影、电视或所有这些领域工作的人，他们都对海格德小说的母题非常熟悉。这就是为什么我认为你在流行文化中一次又一次地看到它们，一直延续到——我猜甚至在英国对非洲的介入发生了彻底改变之后——显然在第二次世界大战后确实如此。
upon layers of history that kind of adventurers are uncovering um terrifying sorceresses all these kinds of things. I mean, they're there all the way through, aren't they? Partly, I suppose, because at the end of Haggard's life, his works were being adapted for the screen in the first kind of Hollywood adventure films and talkies and so on. So all these people, even if they'd never read, you know, King Solomon's Minds or She, all these people who end up working in the
没错，因为它们存在于《夺宝奇兵》（Indiana Jones）中，而且你还提到了电脑游戏。是的。所以我认为，在最近几十年里，对《所罗门王的宝藏》进行了两次重大的重塑，并在全球产生了影响。首先是一种非常英国的视角。那是威尔伯·史密斯（Wilbur Smith）的视角，
cinema or in tv or you know all these things they are intimately familiar with the kind of the themes of haggard's novels and that's why i think you see them again and again in popular culture running all the way through you know into the i suppose into even after the british involvement in africa has completely changed which obviously it does after World War II. Right, because it's there in Indiana Jones and you mentioned computer games. Yeah. And so I think that in recent decades, there have been two kind of massive reworkings of King Solomon's mines that have had global impact. The first is a kind of very British perspective. It's that of Wilbur Smith,
他是一位畅销小说家，可能是有史以来销量最大的非洲小说家。我想他卖出了数百万册。所以他来自罗得西亚。没错。在非洲长大，一生都住在非洲。罗得西亚就是津巴布韦——伟大的津巴布韦遗址所在的地方。当然，在适当的时候，当罗得西亚的白人统治被推翻时，它后来被称为津巴布韦。而大津巴布韦，它可以说是《所罗门王的宝藏》的灵感来源之一——
who's a massive selling novelist, probably the biggest selling, I think, African novelist of all time. I think he sold millions and millions. And so he's from Rhodesia. Right. So grew up in Africa, lived in Africa all his life. And Rhodesia is the place where Zimbabwe, the great ruins of Zimbabwe were. And of course, in due course, when white rule in Rhodesia gets toppled, comes to be called Zimbabwe. And Great Zimbabwe, which is kind of one of the inspirations
我在这里展现了我对年轻威尔伯·史密斯的深入了解，因为在1941年，当这位未来的畅销书作家八岁时，我想，他和父亲进行了一次夜间远征，去参观大津巴布韦的遗址。这些显然留在了他的脑海里，因为几十年后，他写了所有这些极其畅销的书籍，非洲历史、失落的城市等都在其中发挥了作用，不是吗？
for King Solomon's Mines, I'm portraying here my intimate knowledge of the young Wilbur Smith, because in 1941, when the future bestselling writer was eight, I think, he went on this sort of nighttime expedition with his dad to go and see the ruins of Great Zimbabwe. And they obviously stuck in his mind because decades later, he wrote all these massively bestselling books in which kind of African history and lost cities and things like that all play a part, don't they?
是的。这些小说充满了对大英帝国崩溃的遗憾。所以，在这个意义上，坦白说，这是一个相当过时的视角。也许他的小说所获得的成功说明了英国以及更广泛的英联邦人民对这种遗产的感受如何。谁说得准呢？嗯，我认为它们吸引了特定类型的读者，大概是那种不介意有点辛辣文风的读者，汤姆。有可能。威尔伯·史密斯书中的性描写肯定比莱德·海格德书中的要多得多。但另一个我认为对《所罗门王的宝藏》的主题和传统的更近期的重塑，对于听众来说可能是一个稍微意想不到的视角，
Yes. And they're novels that are haunted by regret for the collapse of the British Empire. So, you know, in that sense, quite an unfashionable perspective, I think it would be fair to say. And maybe the success of his novels says something about how people in Britain and in the broader British Commonwealth feel about that legacy. Who can say? Well, I think they appeal to a particular kind of reader, probably sort of a reader who doesn't mind a bit of kind of pungent prose, Tom. Possibly. There's certainly a lot more sex in Wilbur Smith than there is in Ryder Haggard. But the other, I think, reworking, more recent reworking of the themes and traditions of King Solomon's Mines is perhaps for listeners a slightly more unexpected one,
因为它是从某种美国对非洲的视角出发的，那就是《黑豹》（Black Panther）。没错。有趣。因为它是从某种美国对非洲的视角出发的。那就是《黑豹》。没错。有趣。所以《黑豹》是漫威宇宙的一部分。是的。漫威电影宇宙（MCU）的一部分，汤姆。
because it's one that comes from a kind of American perspective on Africa, and that's Black Panther. Right. Interesting. because it's one that comes from a kind of American perspective on Africa. And that's Black Panther. Right. Interesting. So Black Panther is part of the Marvel franchise. Yeah. Part of the MCU, Tom.
MCU，管它是什么。是的。我不知道这意味着什么，但确信它是。它是漫威电影宇宙（Marvel Cinematic Universe）。没错。原来如此。作为蜘蛛侠，你应该对此了如指掌。所以《黑豹》来自非洲的一个失落之城。正如莱德·海格德所说，这些伟大的文明杰作源自腓尼基人。所以在《黑豹》中，这个——
MCU, whatever that is. Yeah. I don't know what that means, but I'm sure it is. It's the Marvel Cinematic Universe. Right. So that's what it is. As Spider-Man, you should know all about this. So Black Panther is from a lost city in Africa. And just as Ryder Haggard says that these great works of civilization derived from Phoenicians. So in Black Panther, the kind
瓦坎达（Wakanda）。瓦坎达。是的。你在《历史的其余部分》（The Rest is History）之前的一集里把这个词发错音了，遭到了听众的大量吐槽。是的，我确实发错了。所以每次我说这个名字时，我都感到紧张，但它源于某种从天而降的奇怪金属，有人吞下了这种金属并获得了超能力。我记得那是振金（Vibranium）。振金。是的。好的。所以腓尼基人对《所罗门王的宝藏》来说，就像振金对《黑豹》一样——也就是说，某种东西解释了为什么非洲中部会崛起一个文明。因此，我会说，这有点
of almost supernatural power that the people of this, what is it? Wakanda. Wakanda. Yes. You mispronounced it in an earlier episode of The Rest is History and got a lot of grief from the listeners. Yes, I did. So every time I say the name, I feel nervous, but it derives from some weird metal that's landed and somebody swallowed this metal and kind of obtained super power. Vibranium, I believe it is. Vibranium. Yeah. Okay. So what the Phoenicians are to King Solomon's mines, vibranium is to Black Panther, i.e. something that explains how a civilization has arised in the middle of Africa. And so therefore, I would say, a little bit
令人怀疑，为什么它需要某种外部的宇宙干预呢？你拥有一个古老的文明，你拥有一个在《黑豹》中字面意义上被高科技屏幕所掩盖的失落之城，一片天堂般的土地。你拥有你在《所罗门王的宝藏》中能找到的所有那种东西。所以你有这样一种感觉：那里的人们，无论是《黑豹》中的勇士还是男女老少，都比你在西方看到的更强壮、更坚韧、更强硬、更酷。他们甚至有敌对竞争者之间的决斗，这非常符合《所罗门王的宝藏》的主题。因此，我认为，尽管《黑豹》这个名字本身就反映了美国自60年代以来的种族政治——我的意思是，在我看来，它无疑受到了《所罗门王的宝藏》那非常出人意料的遗产的影响。
dubious, why should it need kind of outside cosmic intervention? You have an ancient civilization, you have a lost city that is in Black Panther, kind of literally veiled by a kind of high-tech screen, a paradisal land. You have all the kind of stuff that you get in King Solomon's mind. So you have this sense that people there, the warriors and their female as well as male in Black Panther are stronger, harder, tougher, cooler than you'd get in the West. They even have kind of combat between rival contenders, which is very much a theme of King Solomon's Mines. And so I think that even though, obviously, Black Panther, the very name is reflective of the racial politics of America from the 60s onwards. I mean, it does seem to me indubitably to be informed by that very unexpected
在那里发现这一点，比在威尔伯·史密斯的小说中发现它要出乎意料得多。难道这不正印证了我们有时讨论过的观点吗：大约1870年至1930年的流行文化，为我们今天视为理所当然的许多事物奠定了模板？我的意思是，任何玩过电子游戏的人大概都玩过《她》或《所罗门王的宝藏》的某种迭代。我的意思是，它与人们创作侦探小说、间谍小说等处于同一时代。实际上，令人惊叹的是，我们都熟悉的许多流行文化主题和手法，竟然都
legacy of King Solomon's mines. And to find it there is a lot more unexpected, I think, than to find it, say, in the novels of Wilbur Smith. Doesn't that bear out the point though, that we've talked about sometimes that the pop culture of, let's say, 1870 to 1930, establishes the template for so many of the things that we take for granted today. I mean, anybody who plays a video game will probably have played some iteration of She or King Solomon's Mines. I mean, it comes from the same era that people are writing detective fiction, spy novels, all of these things. It's actually extraordinary to think how many of popular cultural themes and devices that we're all familiar with that they
可以追溯到20世纪之交前后的那些年，而且实际上都来自英国的帝国流行文化。几乎就像是《非凡绅士联盟》（League of Extraordinary Gentlemen）。哦，这太棒了，汤姆，这太棒了。我明白你在做什么了。你看，你甚至不知道那是什么。我知道，因为制作人昨天跟你说过。但艾伦·夸特曼就是其中之一。所以那是一本漫画书，艾伦·摩尔（Alan Moore）将19世纪末的所有这些英雄——比如《吸血鬼惊情四百年》中的米娜·哈克（Mina Harker）等——结合在一起，将他们想象成组建了一个类似“复仇者联盟”的组合。而艾伦·夸特曼是其中的核心人物。
date from those years either side of the turn of the 20th century and from actually british imperial pop culture almost like it's a league of extraordinary gentlemen oh that's very good tom that's very good i see what you're doing there you see that i mean you don't even know what that is i know because the producer told you about it yesterday. But Alan Quatermain is one of those. So that's a comic book in which Alan Moore takes all these heroes from the late 19th century, Mina Harker from Dracula and so on, and imagines them, you know, as forming a kind of Avengers-style combo. And Alan Quatermain is the chief figure.
好吧，原来如此。所以他的遗产得以延续。事实上，汤姆，我们已经聊了这么久，而且我以极大的热情谈论了威尔伯·史密斯和所有这些随机的事情，以至于制作人在播客录制过程中实际上已经换人了。所以一个制作人已经回家了。西奥（Theo）已经回家了，由亚历克斯（Alex）取代了。或者这是“她”的魔力。
Well, there you go. So his legacy lives on. And actually, Tom, we've been talking so long, and I'm as such gusto about Wilbur Smith and all these random things, that the producer has actually changed in the course of the podcast. So one producer has gone home. Theo has gone home and been replaced by Alex. Or it's the magical power of she.
很有可能。好吧，我们不要再深入探讨“她”的力量那些非常弗洛伊德式的深渊了，汤姆。这就是H·莱德·海格德。我们将会回归，汤姆，我们将带着……克伦威尔的——克伦威尔的英国，以及爱尔兰。克伦威尔的英国，我想克伦威尔会喜欢所有这些东西的？我想他会有一点点喜欢。我想他会觉得这有点不敬神。是的，这确实有点不敬神。但其中有一部分他可能会非常乐意……
It could well be. Well, let's not delve deeper into those very freudian depths tom of uh the powers of she so that's h rider haggard we will be returning what will be returning with tom uh with uh cromwell's cromwell's uh britain and indeed island cromwell's britain which i think cromwell would have loved all this stuff? I think a little bit of him. I think he'd have found it a touch ungodly. Yeah, it is a bit ungodly. But there's the bit of him that would have probably been well up for...
很可能是这样。好吧，汤姆，我们不要再深入探讨那些非常弗洛伊德式的深渊了，关于《她》的力量。这就是H·莱德·哈格德，我们将回归，我们将和汤姆一起回归，探讨克伦威尔的克伦威尔的英国，以及爱尔兰，克伦威尔的英国，我想克伦威尔会喜欢所有这些东西的？我想他身上会有一点。我想他会觉得这有点不敬神。是的，这确实有点不敬神。但他的骨子里其实也有一部分可能会非常支持……
I think he'd have enjoyed an adventure, didn't he? This is madness. I mean, would Oliver Cromwell have enjoyed the novels of King Solomon's mind? These are the questions that we dare to ask. That no other podcast will bring you. Right. And on that note, we will say thank you very much for listening and goodbye bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip
我想他会喜欢一次冒险的，不是吗？这太疯狂了。我的意思是，奥利弗·克伦威尔会喜欢《所罗门王的宝藏》这类小说吗？这些是我们敢于提出的问题，是其他任何播客都无法带给你的。没错。基于此，我们要非常感谢大家的收听，再见。谢谢大家收听《The Rest Is History》，要想收听独家节目、提前解锁、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我们还主持了《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这是你获取每周娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的固定栏目
and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐行业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、独家节目以及优先购买现场门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是... 本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。